he created a body that was to become the
gold standard for muscular development
he would use it to achieve one goal
after another rising to the very
pinnacle of not one but three careers
from the very start Arnold
Schwarzenegger had the odds stacked
against him he was dismissed he was
ridiculed he was parodied all
mercilessly what people failed to
realize was that Arnold's strongest
muscle there wasn't his biceps
it was his brain with it he orchestrated
career moves that took him to the very
very top in this biographic video we're
going to uncover the unlikely rags to
riches story of the one and only Arnold
Schwarzenegger
[Music]
Arnold Schwarzenegger was born in the
tiny an Austrian village of thaal near
Grant's on July 30 at the 1947 his
father Gustav was the local police chief
Arnold and his older brother mine hard
grew up under the tough discipline of a
man who was used to being a bait
Arnold's early years they were
incredibly regimented he'd be up at 6:00
and then off to get her milked from the
farm next door then he would have to do
a set of physical exercises that his
father had written out for him he would
earn his breakfast upon doing a certain
number of sit-ups in the afternoon after
it finished his homework and chores his
father made Arnold and mynhardt practice
soccer no matter how bad the weather was
if they messed up on a play they got
yelled at Gustav had been a champion ice
color in his younger years and he pushed
his sons to excel physically with his
father's pushing eyelid first got into
competitive sports at the age of 10 he
played soccer passionately for almost 5
years when he was 15 Arnold soccer coach
decided that lifting weights for an hour
once a week would be a good way for his
players to stay in shape so he took them
for a visit to the local gym this is a
day if it would absolutely change
Arnold's life he was mesmerized by the
sheer size of the bodybuilders who stalk
to the gym waging war with steel weights
Ahnold would later record his feelings
in his 1977 autobiography Arnold's the
education of a bodybuilder there it was
before me my life the answer I'd been
seeking it clicked it was something I
suddenly just seemed to reach out and
find as if I'd been crossing a suspended
bridge and finally stepped off onto
solid ground Arnold embraced
weightlifting he soon discovered that he
had an amazing ability to build muscle
and within two years he had already
overtaken most of the other trainers at
the gym and grants where he worked out
religiously he also trained harder than
anyone else
one Sunday discovering that the gym was
closed he actually smashed the window in
order to get in so that he could
complete his workout Arnold's father
though he was less than impressed with
this son's newfound obsession
bodybuilding it was really a fringe
sport in Austria at that time with those
who partook of its being looked down
upon
and considered in some way defective
when it was discovered that Arnold had
pictures of half-naked men with bulging
muscles on his bedroom wall a
psychiatrist was called in to save
Arnold from himself the psychologist
assured his parents that this was simply
a phase and Arnold would absolutely grow
out of it and well as you probably know
he absolutely didn't by the age of 17
Arnold had already realized the
bodybuilding was going to be his vehicle
to worldwide fame he spent many Saturday
afternoons down at the local movie
theater watching bodybuilders turned
actors such as Steve Reeves and his
personal favorite bench park he watched
them on screen playing Hercules and
other mythic heroes they had used
bodybuilding in order to create careers
as movie stars and that was exactly what
Arnold wanted to do only he was going to
be bigger and better than any of them
[Music]
Arnold he entered the Austrian army in
1965 in order to fulfill his 1 year of
service by now had built his body to 200
pounds of Herculean muscle he was
assigned as a driver in a tank unit
shortly after he was inducted Arnold
received an invitation to compete in the
Junior Division of the mr. Europe
contest in Stuttgart Germany but he was
in the middle of basic training no
soldier was allowed to leave the base
for any reason but Arnold knew that his
destiny was tied with winning this
contest so he decided to go a while they
in order to compete he crawled over the
world taking only the clothes he was
wearing and barely enough money to buy a
third-class ticket to Germany when he
arrived to the competition he actually
had to borrow someone else's posing
trunks and their tanning oil still his
muscles were undeniable and that night
he was announced junior mr. Europe at
first the army they were not exactly
impressed me was actually jailed for
seven days with only a blanket on a cold
stone bench and almost no food but
within a few days the news of his
victory had spread and the top brass
decided that the title added prestige to
the army when he returned to the ranks
he was held up as a sort of ideal with
his drill instructor telling the troops
you have to fight for your fatherland
you have to take courage look at what
Schwarzenegger did just to win this
title not following his stint in the
Army Arnold took a job as a gym
instructor at a health club in Munich
Germany this presented him with the
ideal opportunity to train for the 1966
mr. Europe competition this was the next
step in his master plan to become the
best-built man on the planet he trained
twice a day working like a man zest in
order to forge his winning physique by
the time he arrived in Stuttgart for the
mr. Europe contest people were anxious
to get a look at this monster from
Munich the one that there'd heard rumors
all about all of the attention infused
Arnold with a great deal of confidence
and he already felt like the winner
Arnold's win the day was so emphatic
that the judges offered to pay his way
to the upcoming Mr Universe contest he
arrived in London having almost no
English but as soon as he stepped out of
his cab
people began bobbing him they had all
been waiting for him the first
bodybuilder in Europe with 20-inch arms
but unfortunately he didn't win that
date the American
shorten had a more complete to find
physique and he forced Arnold to accept
second place Arnold returned to Munich
and threw himself back into his training
he shot everything out of his mind and
concentrated on only one thing winning
at the 1967 mister Universe competition
and sure enough on September the 23rd
1967 Arnold Schwarzenegger became at 20
years of age the youngest mr. universe
in history a year later and even more
massive Arnold returned to London to
claim the professional mr. Universe
title following that victory Arnold
received the phone call that would prove
to be the next great signpost to his
future on the other end of the line it
was Joe Weider
bodybuilding guru and publisher of
muscle builder magazine wider invited
Arnold to compete in the IFBB mr.
universe in Miami and then come to train
in California and work for him
Arnold arrived in America in September
1968 with a gym bag 20 US dollars and
still virtually no English he settled
into a small apartment in Venice Beach
and was given a small stipend by wieder
in exchange for the rights to use his
image in magazines
Arnold's plan was to stay in the USA for
one year absorb their training
strategies and then used them to beat
the Americans at their own game
Arnold's began training at a small gym
at Venice Beach Los Angeles called
Gold's Gym he rubbed shoulders with all
the American top bodybuilders that
quickly established himself as the
leader of the pack in 1970 Arnold he won
the coveted Triple Crown of bodybuilding
claiming of the mr. universe mr. world
and the mr. Olympia titles he was now
the undisputed king of bodybuilding
Arnold went on to win six consecutive
mr. Olympia titles as he completely
dominated the sport and with this well
he was ready to implement phase two
there was master plan
[Music]
in IT service EJ wieder got a call from
a film production company looking for a
bodybuilder to play Hercules in a
low-budget film why did he immediately
thought of Arnold telling the producer
that Arnie had been a Shakespearean
actor back in Europe they signed him up
immediately the result was Hercules goes
to New York and it was to be Arnold's
first and most forgettable film his
credits read Arnold strong and his thick
Austrian accents was actually dubbed
over still they got paid $10,000 which
he invested into California real estate
his next paycheck well it actually took
some time coming because Arnold found
Hollywood's less receptive than he had
hoped several agents had told him that
he had everything going against him he
had a long name which was difficult to
pronounce a strange accent and top it
all off and unusual build which will
never make it into films for Arnold this
was the very motivation that he needed
back in Austria he had been told that he
could never become a champion
bodybuilder and yet that is exactly what
he became now he would reinvent himself
through the same a sheer hard work and
dedication that he had learnt in the gym
in order to become the highest-paid
movie star on the planet he would make
those agents words
Arnold's he began acting lessons in 1974
he won a supporting role in the Bob
Rafelson movie stay hungry in this movie
he played a bodybuilder named Joe Santos
oh is hardly stretched his acting
ability still he was absolutely
determined to make an impression and
well make an impression he did he wanted
the Golden Globe for Best Newcomer then
in 1977 the documentary pumping iron
opened in theaters the film chronicled
Arnold's victory in the 1975 mr. Olympia
over the Lou Ferrigno the future
Incredible Hulk as his charming
confident self Arnold's on-screen
charisma it was impossible to resist
pumping iron led to small roles in
movies the villain and the Jayne
Mansfield story
[Music]
by this point in his life Arnold's he
was already a successful businessman he
was combining real estate investments
best-selling biography and bodybuilding
training courses this meant that he
could afford to wait for just the right
film project he felt his time with
public appearances and social functions
one such function was the Robert F
Kennedy tennis tournaments in
Hyannisport there he caught the eye of a
beautiful dark-haired girl by the name
of Maria Shriver she was the daughter of
Chardonnay and eunice Kennedy Shriver
and the niece of John Fitzgerald Kennedy
Arnold and Maria while they fell in love
at first sight
the Shrivers they were great for LAN
through fists and through them Arnold
was introduced to the Special Olympics
which he has been passionately involved
with ever since in 1979 olive began a
career as a CBS sports commentator he
also graduated from the University of
Wisconsin with a business degree but it
was a year later that he stunned the
bodybuilding world with his comeback at
the mr. Olympia competition in Australia
there he captured his seventh title
cementing his legendary status as the
greatest bodybuilder of all time
Arnold's comeback though it wasn't
without controversy he went to Australia
in the role of a TV reporter only
signing his name to the register at the
last minute he was also good friends
with the head judge bodybuilding legend
bill pearl the general consensus was
that Arnold on stage was a mere shadow
of his former self his victory was the
first time actually greeted by boos
still he had his seventh mr. Olympia
title
[Music]
the great shape that Arnold had got into
for the 1980 mr. Olympia propelled him
to his breakthrough role as Conan the
Barbarian after spending a year in
training working on his speech and
learning how to use iron
broadswords he had it off to Yugoslavia
and Spain for a grueling six-month sheet
Conan the Barbarian it raked in more
than a hundred million dollars at the
box office together with its sequel
Conan the Destroyer it firmly embedded
the name arnold schwarzenegger into
moviegoers consciousnesses following his
success with the conan movies Arnold was
offered a low-budget movie by first-time
director and screenwriter James Cameron
this where they would prove to be his
most iconic role in the Terminator
Arnold plays a cyborg sent back in time
to kill the mother of the man who will
save humankind from destruction the role
well it was made for Arnold his accent
and his body the very things that agents
have said would work against him were
perfect for the part of the t1000 The
Terminator was an absolute smash firmly
establishing Arnold as the next great
action star by 1985 had already been
named international star of the year and
on April the 26th 1986 Arnold's a
staunch Republican as Maria Shriver a
member of Democratic royalty what they
were married but their honeymoon it was
barely over before Arnold flew to Mexico
to film his latest action blockbuster
predator this movie again won in the
title action star of the year after a
string of action films commando rawdy or
predator in the running man the forward
thinking Arnold was ready for a new
challenge and that challenge was comedy
so unsurprisingly very few were willing
to take a gamble on Arnold as a comic
actor but one who was was the director
Ivan Reitman who created a special
vehicle for Arnold this vehicle but it
was called twins the irresistible
chemistry of Schwarzenegger and Danny
DeVito made twins an immediate hit and
two years later
Arnold again teamed up with reitman for
kindergarten caught another comedy
success a large part of the success of
these films it's Arnold's ability to
laugh at himself
Arnold's always got the joke which was
really endearing to fans over and above
that Arnold's also a gifted comedian as
anyone
you seen something on will no now one
person who noticed Arnold's abilities on
kindergarten cough especially his
rapport with children was President
George Bush Bush appointed Arnold as the
chairman of the President's Council on
physical fitness now this could have
really been a symbolic Robert Arnold he
totally threw himself into it with
absolute relish visiting every state in
order to promote the fitness lifestyle
now this movie winning streak it totally
continued for our not yet Total Recall
and Terminator 2 this sequel cost one
hundred and two million dollars making
it the most expensive film at the time
it returns an astonishing five hundred
and nineteen point eight million dollars
with Arnie pocketing a cool 50 million
now Arnold's next vagary the outing was
lost action hero a 100 million dollar
extravaganza which seemed like a sure
thing the film it was a box-office bomb
and a critical flop hollywood's was
really quick to tear Arnie down claiming
that his time in the limelight was over
but Schwarzenegger
he had other ideas he bounced back from
defeat with the same focus determination
as in his bodybuilding days he reteamed
with James Cameron for the action-packed
James Bond spoof True Lies well the
movie was a smash Arnold's critics were
once again silenced and he was back on
top
[Music]
in the mid-1990s Alma began focusing on
giving back to the country that had
given him so much he became an organizer
and sponsor of the annual inner-city
games he was also very involved in the
after-school care program in 2003 during
an appearance on the Jay Leno Show
Arnold announced his candidacy for
governor of California this was
following the recall of Governor Gray
Davis sparked by the California
electricity crisis Arnold P ran an
energetic campaign despite a smear
campaign organized by the LA Times a
number of women claimed that over the
years Arnold had molested them while
others claimed to have had affairs with
him still Arnold he was able to rise
above this with his unique mix of charm
intelligence and wit on one occasion
someone threw an egg which splattered
emani's jacket he immediately whipped
the jacket off threw it over his
shoulder and called out hey I will be
bacon with those eggs ani
he easily won the governorship hands
immediately set about cleaning house at
Sacramento bringing his own unique style
to the position such as calling his
Democratic opposition girly men Arnold's
first term it was marked by such early
victories as repealing a vehicle license
increase and stopping illegals from
getting driver's licenses but then
powerful state unions began to oppose
his initiatives and for ballot measures
he sponsored in a special election in
2005 they were defeated
despite this Arnold he was re-elected
governor in 2006 with 56% of the vote on
his second term he put a lot of effort
into environmental issues in 2006 he
signs the global warming solutions Act
making California the first state to put
a cap on greenhouse gas emissions
Arnold's second term as governor it came
to an end in January of 2011 a few
months later the LA Times ran a cover
story reporting that Ahnold had fathered
a child 14 years previously with the
family's long-term mate as a direct
result of this revelation Arnold a Maria
ended their 25-year marriage she and
their four children moved out of the
family home in Brentwood
Arnold's post governorship movie career
has seen him feature in such action
flicks as the Expendables 2 and 3 escape
plan
sabotage and the fifth installment
Terminator in which he battles his
younger self Arnold he has maintained
strong ties to the bodybuilding world
following his retirement from the sport
in 1975 he promoted the mr. Olympia
competition then in 1989 he and longtime
partner Jim Lorimer started the Arnold
Schwarzenegger classic which is now the
second biggest pro bodybuilding show
just behind mr. Olympia Arnold credits
all of his success to the
self-discipline Drive and focus that he
learns from his bodybuilding career in
more recent time solid has been involved
in a social media feud with President
Donald Trump in the wake of Annie
replacing Trump on Celebrity Apprentice
Trump blames on work for the show's
dismal ratings and Arnold offered the
commander-in-chief some timely advice on
how to run the country Arnold a staunch
Republican refused to vote for Trump in
the 2016 presidential election the first
time he had not supported the Republican
candidate since becoming a US citizen
although it's a battle we would all love
to see unfortunately Arnold's can't
challenge the Donald for the top job as
he wasn't born in the United States even
though he did become a citizen in 1983
Arnold well today he still lives the
fitness lifestyle he just celebrated its
70th birthday he still works out every
day so I really hope you found the video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and do not
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
just like this every Monday and Thursday
also check out some of our other videos
that are over there on the right and as
always I'll see you in the next one